yeah lucky charms fell out of favor for  me and then i and then it came back  i mean i can't remember the last time i  made lucky charms  it's because it's like wood except when  marshmallows in it no no one agrees with  that  nobody wants nobody wants the the brown  parts  nobody wants to taste  yeah yeah no not that's who not not  that's not true could you imagine eating  a bowl of just that's a yin yang if you  had a bowl of just the tan those make  the marshmallows more of a treat  that's what i tried to do all  marshmallows and you take it and you're  just like you're literally gonna die  that night  it's a bowl of [ __ ] it's like it's too  much  my head's going nuts right now all right  let's take it back let's take